this this by the way um like I said I
know you're not gonna be assess on in
your most current assessment but some
questions away they are away the little
red flag and I'll say you know just my
own from my experience of this
assessment this kind of science topic
these are the kinds of questions which
are going to come up right so it is
absolutely in your interest not just to
be able to do them but to actually
master them and be able to sort of do
these have these kinds of questions as
that I could do these in my sleep type
questions right some questions is not
worth wasting your time like this
question I would probably don't waste
any time so the way I really got to
memorize this approach okay
the strategy is not that hard but there
is a there is a length to it that you
can't avoid these kind of questions
though you're gonna get you gonna meet
this if you don't made it in the next
assessment you made in the one after
that
where you meet in the HSA you meet it
eventually okay so let's have a go at
this consider the coefficient of x and 0
in that another way that you would um
see this phrase is um what's the
constant term in this expansion because
X to the 0 is 1 right so it's like when
I expand this all out and I collect all
my like terms I'll have a whole bunch of
X's and or like x squared and X cubed
and on X's and Bawa and then at the end
I'll have a number right what's the
number okay so how do I work it out when
you have a look at this thing right how
I look at the powers right individually
I can expand these guys out and I will
do that in fact I'll do it right now
okay
so the power of 3 into the power to
these are number smaller I don't need to
write out Pascal's triangle for these so
I'm gonna have one - because there's a
negative sign right 3x on 3 there's my
first one right then I'm gonna have 3x
on 3 Square following so far right and
then I'm gonna have an odd number Nixon
be - and it'll be X on 3 the biggest one
cubes okay good there's one now for
reasons it'll become clear in a second
not just because I've ran out space
I'm gonna write the next one on the next
line
you see one second squared if I'm going
to have one two one that's not so hot so
and it's positive one plus two of those
plus one of those okay you happy so far
is it not too hot now at this point you
start to see where you need to not just
you know bash your way through it but
you need to apply a bit of you to be a
bit more thoughtful about it if I were
to do this multiplication out right if I
were to expand this fully before I even
touches I already know it's going to be
a tough job right how many terms will
there be in the expansion have a think
I've got four terms up here but I've got
three down here I will have twelve turns
right not only is that going to cost me
a lot of time just to calculate all of
them but it's very error-prone right
it's just numbers flying everywhere it's
asking for an era like you know missing
a minus sign or something like that and
also the question tells you you don't
need all of them you only need out of
the twelve there will only be some that
are actually relevant to the question
right so the question is well which
terms will be relevant now if you have a
look at this right how do we expand
things and you've got a whole bunch of
times here at how much return to you
well the approach should be okay you
take one term and then you multiply it
by all the others in the other brackets
then you go to the next one and you
multiply them all and so on right and
you end up with 12 terms but you can see
if I started to write them right just
mentally think with me if I did this one
multiplied by all three terms here right
you have one by one is that a term I
want it is because it'll be a constant
term right so that one's that one's good
right but they will figure out the next
one I can immediately discard it right
because it won't be a constant term
it'll be forever X right so I could
ignore it but I'd look at the next one
again I could ignore it in fact every
time I do this there will only ever be
one term in the expansion if that that's
going to be useful right the first one
will be 1 times 1 when I do that at this
one have a look is this times this going
to give me a constant term it's a no
because they'll be next there and then
there's nothing to get rid of the X but
when you go to the next one
it works I've got an X on the numerator
excellent denominator you end up with
the constant here you have an x squared
and here I'm dividing by x squared so
that'll work right and then when I
multiply this sky by all of these terms
well it turns out that none of them are
useful right because that X cubed on the
top has nerd divided by X cube to match
with does that make sense so I can
ignore that right away okay so now I
have rather reduced my problem I don't
need to work out 12 terms I only need to
work out three okay now please please
please please at this point in your
working do not say equals and then say
one minus whatever that is plus whatever
that is okay because that is not equal
to that right what am I trying to work
out sorry I've already worked out
through that I've done the first term
and undoing the second okay
what am i working out I'm actually
working out this question there okay so
don't just blindly put an equal sign
there I'm working out something
different so you should say what you are
working out that's different okay I
would write out well which of the terms
that I'm interested in and then the X to
the zero terms right where they gonna be
equal to um if there was a coefficient
of x squared in there I don't care what
the x squared either should care about
the numbers so you could write x to the
zero coefficients if you like but in
this case they're the same alright so
here we gotta go 1 times 1 1 minus 3
times 2 will give me minus 6 and then
I've got what's inside the brackets as
well right so I've got 2 over 3 you see
that I don't have to worry about any of
the exes because I'm just looking for
the constant term and I've chosen the
ones where they're gonna exactly cancel
here 3 by 1 is that coefficient at the
front and then I've got careful what's
inside the brackets been squared right
so I'm going to have 2 over 3 square
happy with that and that's it really I
mean the rest of it's just arithmetic ok
one minus that looks like four to me
plus three one of them cancel with there
looks like
four three three three yeah minus three
plus 4/3
I think that's minus 5/3
okay so you see right being able to see
this pattern okay twelve terms you
probably could do twelve terms that will
be just the bottom of threshold where I
would say okay stop stop working this
out now but I could very easily make
this question impossible impractical to
do by actually working all the time if I
just did this let's just what's that
that's a six but that's 24 terms okay
you're gonna be doing that whole
question to MacKinnon and sunsets and
then you know the cleaner or say I need
to mock up now and then you need to go
home so there are questions like this
way you must employ this approach bring
the question there yeah absolutely it
could be something that just makes it
like this is actually not too bad to
consider okay but nonetheless you know
reducing the problem is fine you can is
the way to go
always